hello ever come to our Monday live show
yeah so we won again here for one hour
of blitz on the ICC five-minute pool
let's get this going style I got a game
immediately either gladiator is my
opponent so that's our field master
Hoffman right asa Hoffman that true is
offered right USC have rated highest
senior blitz play in the u.s. played
Bobby Fischer hundreds of blitz games
yeah that's certainly a cool cool thing
to the same again so yeah he's an old
timer but yeah he's a i think a big your
cursor probably played fisher in his
youth and let's see what we get do I get
a bank oh and nope hunk of the trompe um
so stream looks fine I think it does
okay probably goes to five now and this
is an interesting variation for both
sides actually to play it's quite quite
complicated so he played this um more
more conservative fashion let's see i
can go five i can go is sex I don't know
if he's six is a month I think I'll wait
form over time okay he goes a form
yeah I wonder maybe I can prepare this
like a 6b five and so on can you
flipping at this pawn but is he able to
make more pressure on that probably no
point interesting I think I'll go for
that here we has 95 hmm I was thinking
of 93 mostly yes that's definitely an
option the night coming to c 6 that's a
pretty pretty big whole world hmm very
difficult yeah if he goes here and I'll
take it and go a c6 is that bad for
black maybe it is but maybe I get to
spawn ultimately yes someone in the shed
saying make Trump great again yeah this
is the Trump not the Trump it would be
funny if there was a trump opening yeah
Donald Trump yet some weird state money
about us chests that they don't have any
grand masters or something like that
which is a pretty funny statement
considering that they have won the chess
olympiad in grand style well okay so i
think i'll get this pawn right looks
like i get to pawn yeah you note my
rating isn't all that great compared to
what I have or what I sometimes have I
didn't have a good tag would run last
weekend and lost a couple of points
maybe I can get some points back today
maybe before but I want to get c64
us before anything else his pieces look
a little bit strange now we have them
the night on age three and the bishop on
g2 they both don't they both they don't
do all that much and c3 is a pretty
substantial weakness yeah like it takes
III him Queen takes or queen takes or
context or Bishop takes Queen takes what
is he doing maybe back or something I
think I'll still take queen is a queen
a7la I mean with back yeah okay let's
get this rolling rolling rolling rolling
Queen to f5 he might take take d5 that
doesn't look great well night h5 doesn't
threaten all that much actually does it
threaten much
just a moment here to check it out
unify this is not totally wrong yeah
it's a pawn for basically nothing but
but I sometimes screw things up if it
even simple things so a second stop
fairly fairly easily right to stage 6
and now look at eight and a one maybe d4
here right let's open the song
so um any idea here for him not really I
have this one though I check the look
now that should be the end of it
actually I don't see any defense quite
resigned yeah so starting over the win
that's nice let's hope that this
persists in the session I don't know
what the opponents are currently in the
pool where are some good ones some good
ones wallah casse not on unfortunately
that was funny i think last time i had
20 legis games game started aha playing
alexia with with black what does he do
against the dutch defense oh yeah Bishop
g5 hmm ok and school is six yeah here
black probably should play for a stone
wall it makes a make sense to do J what
is wife doing here playing for the the
counter stone wall maybe yeah this is
not particularly exciting but
objectively pretty good this is this
counter Stonewall f4 nope doesn't do it
I was expecting this
it just takes everything and now I for
okay well yeah I can go g5 but he has to
check unfortunately it takes the fun out
of it what if I try this yeah h6 and g5
is said something
no that looks interesting I mean Castle
g5 I don't know if this is so so great
for white top yeah this is this is
gorgeou I absolutely like the King there
you know I threatening g for now and
trapping the queen with Bishop e8 so yes
to think about this no and you did so
let's get going here like a little bit
like banco de banco gambit style let's
let's get rolling I have to do it now if
I give him more time to get his stuff
coordinated then things are not that
clear so what's the deal here maybe this
just closing this down and play with the
play with a light space here yes if I
can at best take so I think I double
like that there's a request for the cow
can open in yeah I can play that I mean
I'm not not an expert but sometimes play
this even a tournament share so it's not
it's not like I have no idea is he
playing for some e for business doesn't
look like it
so I've got the H file but yes that
currently currently covered I'm just
going to push this forward this position
I think all the space should mean
something maybe after c4 maybe you can
take how let's cover this first and get
a bit more coordination going yes you
for now we can take em cannot do that I
need my my rooks now transferred I try
to play on the Kings side but it ends up
being a king side attack on on his and
his Queen side Bishop f4 was already
winning actually I came whatever b3 I
can take it's made on a 1 I could have
done that earlier one move earlier I
didn't need ruka jail but I spotted it
too late this should win the exchange at
least nine is 3k grab it 95 no that's
not not that dangerous I think
so what's the deal here I still have to
be cautious he has those those desperado
sacrifices if I play as before he will
take so this is not not that it clear d
4d for might be enough might be enough
but it looks a little bit wrong add
deform doesn't look right not sure how
to precisely win Bishop takes 25 my beer
might be on let's do it i mean i'm not
happy about the move but i lost too much
time he already okay now this is
probably not the best way to do it okay
what does that take white resigns hi I
mean it probably was winning anyway
somehow but tricky business if he
doesn't give me the might okay let's see
if I get into and you get going it's a
Sicilian dragon solid as consultants
question
well and I think it's probably a little
bit shaky if white is playing absolutely
perfect chess game start and I'm not
shaky in a way that you're getting chick
mated but that white might have a better
ending or so I recently checked some
some things and it feels like my tum
maintains a slight advantage but I'm not
a super big expert so it's not like you
should take my absolute word and say
fantastic and so on so I'll get this
year the improved stylist my best play
was on the game 2035 let us never seen a
camera right as this I way I vaguely
remember that just probably Nakamura
with a cat that's lucky moment yeah
we're beat him on one video yeah well
the dragon isn't is a very interesting
opening and it can never be a thing
totally terrible but the last time I
checked and this was yesterday actually
White has chance to get an advantage
with the nine long castles sorry hahaha
Gagne I am and this is the thing I have
my my openings my usual repertoire and I
tend to attend to just play like quickly
what I usually do and them I'm sorry and
I try next try in the next game to play
the car oh so I'm just bringing every
piece here in the general direction of
the King side and see what comes of it
eirick here's some going ahead here on
the queenside so what am i doing
here if I go a form is he going to
deform I can take here maybe I should
bring the King here to add some what's a
foursquare so now if I am 94 i take c 5
and take d 5 or not I just win the
center part I think and no i don't but
it's that dangerous okay I mean this is
hanging with a check then I probably
have to do this which isn't a big
problem okay cool takes and context c-54
day but I should have a really good
position here because of the general
activity here so 94 94 to attack this
night probably is the car was often
often a better version of the crew d8
Scandinavian hmm i don't think you can
make that comparison I mean there are
definite similarities between the
caro-kann and the Scandinavian but in
the car oh I mean why can't play re5
first first of all the advance which is
probably the best line anyway so yeah
that's what is this Queen edge form yeah
we double a double attack here isn't
this basically over I can also play look
to the eighth and maybe drive the Queen
even further away might make sense yeah
in particular i looked it too
in the couch and white can play the
advanced variation and this is not easy
at all in the Scandinavian you force the
structure this typical structure cool I
didn't see this move but I have f4 here
F for the specially curve yeah the
special curve is a very complex opening
I don't know I mean I think I mean even
as a club player you can play it as
definitely definitely very interesting
no there's nothing great on the
caro-kann two nights Claude probably the
best in terms of a book you can get is
that book the Blitz openings by special
event / shake off the father and son
combination so f three right this is
doing the trick or he's got this bloody
Queen g3 I have night III year also and
I have not aged for some there's some
nice lines him how to do this year how
to do this f3 takes take screen g3 no I
cannot take I know he can take em so if
i do this f3 well i'm slow here f3 you
can make like fringe III immediately i
would like to stop that you know not if
three also looks strong but i don't see
how it wins this is the problem I don't
see a wind down time morning probably a
couple of things win but I want to do
something decisive here
no night each horse it looks very strong
let's do this come on I have to play a
move him yes so this one no that isn't
made what isn't that made that's a shame
okay so I didn't plan that beforehand
maybe it just does the trick so I'm
threatening age three now I only have 20
seconds is the problem rook g1 might
might winner she won this one shoot I
screwed up I screwed this game up in
this position which was probably winning
multiple times I didn't find it on here
another trait screens oh my god what is
what it what a game oh god I'm such a
[ __ ] okay black eyes I yea sorry I'm
sorry I need to check this I mean I
completely I completely switched off
here thinking everything wins but in
night this this actually does win minus
11 but and calm but here it isn't all
that easy right we drop these three this
losers okay rook these three year wins
though this wins but he just completely
just takes here and then kf3 huh so this
doesn't work I just ok so here the
moment where I really took the long
thing only route III does win
and it's not that easy but I mean I
should I should see this this is pretty
and pretty clean so what was my problem
and what did I overlooked here calm
actually I wanted to play f3 that was my
plan but he has this move this is what I
didn't see beforehand it is actually
making a case for not playing I'm not
playing this route d8 stuff and this is
an immediate win yachting language and
these stupid games they cost enormous
points yeah it's a I mean he basically
gives me the point yeah on a silver
plate with this play and I don't take it
nigeria this is a very difficult
position for white anyway okay with some
time the engine so when you started okay
Jean that that's a new opponent ok I
think I have to let's play the dragon
yeah this is this seems to be best down
I i checked i checked with the computer
Queen a five in this position so is he
going for some sacrifices then don't see
it Bishop h6 looks possible in this
position I do stockfish stop 474 the
computer checks so
okay he wants to go Brooks III I can't
play Knight B three-year first orgy five
groups III takes on f6 that's probably
also quite good okay just goes to to h5
hmm well the dragon is not my best known
opening so I should be on the lookout
gem that I'm not blundering something
stupid probably that wasn't the best m
probably not night f5 that could be
something hardly i'm just threatening to
take on seven if i do this here maybe
keeping the initiative rolling yeah it's
it's still somewhat boxed in here I am I
queen I hope I'm not blundering into
some some weird thing here it can easily
happen
the shareholder variation from white in
the Sicilian let screen txt phone
beforehand like here Quinn text before
yeah it's probably interesting it has
been played by cars and so it cannot be
totally bad so um yeah in the chat as i
say i'm killing black e'er I don't know
if he goes he six how am i killing him I
don't see it I can't I simply don't see
him mmm what do I do now Knight f6 is
probably wrong f6 doesn't threaten much
where'd you go neither for stupid 93
Maivia I didn't want to take that that
looked wrong opening his files there if
you take on a 5 I take with the naija h5
is still hanging I'm still not sure yeah
he might play that Queen f8 if he gives
up the d6 pawn that it's not the end of
the world champ hmm yeah I'm still not
so happy with the Queen down on age six
probably bishop age 6 ng5 in particular
g5 probably was wasn't the best d5 ok so
i was thinking Knight g4 could be an
idea in some cases or maybe now take and
Bishop age three and it's tickets to
this and take I light a seven I have to
be very very good now
good night to have seven I was so stupid
why did i do that if I go like that it's
already probably lost the area Bishop
age 327 I have no way to prevent it I
I'm an amazing Moragne great great stuff
and it's so easy Queenie 7 and it's the
most natural move anyway okay yeah this
probably also works night of seven let's
solve the idea before this is the thing
I really saw it it's not like it comes
as a total surprise
um goddamn it and that that's really bad
yeah that's really terrible ha losing
against this crap line I'm sorry is this
is Bishop e7 is just rubbish but the way
I played it this is even more rubbish
yeah chat unfortunately Queen f6 them
but I had no one to move anyway
the child also wins of course for him
but I ass got two extra nights okay I
can resign that there was a vast
resigned extremely stupid loss I mean
epic epic I'm tuning my own Queen area
after ft x e6 I don't know how it is if
I don't take but that was extremely bad
okay let's get some some wins and it
really showed ya out of three winning
position one point is pretty bad wyd
against TM pretty cool capri i think is
nowadays a grandmaster so what does he
do the night off okay yes is one of one
of many possible lines that black cassia
against the setup yeah many options both
castles are also possible long and short
against the French defense there's a
question what what should be played and
of course there are many options are
usually reckon alee play the tirage
because I don't really know the
complicated lines said well with 93 but
you can play many things Knight c3 is
theoretically the most challenging so
let's get forward here f5 I don't know
about this I'm not so much at home in
the Sicilian with wine but I'm currently
trying to try to play this a bit in my
games so g6 immediately or 95 is also
coming into consideration the sacrifice
it doesn't look all that all that
tempting
have to say I think I'm going going with
this maybe just goes have six probably
just have six foot black possible course
possible and so I was licking cringey
for here just just attack g6 yeah it's a
simple way to do it and just cancel yeah
I mean blacks the tech is probably just
a bit quicker so it makes perfect sense
let's do this I wonder if it is an idea
for him to just take on on c3 with the
bishop is of course extremely strong I
have a check here is that something come
let's repeat once doesn't hurt yeah I
don't know I have an excellent score
against this player but normally we play
some Kings Indians and so on one if
force is new for me I usually did very
well in those kings onions but I wanted
to stick with some new ideas yeah I
don't know it said so bad for me maybe
you can just play Queen to f7 go for
Queen trade and ending is very very
favorable for black okay so hmm I want
to do here is there some way to get rid
of the bush
if I can do that I'm certainly happy not
easy Anna and 95 takes take this Bishop
f5 always H Wayne Bishop h3 could be
could be something and this activates a
piece lab this is breaking the cover of
g7 h4 h5 could be something or Bishop 83
root g 1 this is coming I have 92 795 no
probably not I think I put this I put
this first put this on g7
okay so Bishop age three and would this
blocks the H file now this is what I
don't like about this move Pusha page
three rook age seven I don't have a
clean a clear continuation after that
it's a problem should f1 and you might
just take it well maybe this is not so
bad all my time I have to watch out for
the time objectively this is probably
lost but can always try look f2 so
what's the deal if i get rid of this
bishop I'm checkmating him but it's not
clear what how to do it with what
happened if i take this now that's a
useless piece anyway and now some
something against against this Bishop my
time morning don't don't get to it
really and then you should be four or
something it could be possible very
wacky I don't night take they can take
with a night action
I wanted to go Bishop before that
doesn't doesn't work and now h5 h6
doesn't do it I don't really have
something here okay cat Jim that's the
end of it
i'm still not resigning
I mean I have managed to Toulouse
positions like that
check check I'm a queen Chang okay you
found this window came I hey so what's a
great serious here yeah that didn't that
didn't work that didn't work at all not
a good opening result here in this game
so let's go for the next game that is
what is that like three three losses
right grade two wins and three losses
Wow and I definitely don't want to fall
below 2,300 then I feel like I don't
know really bad side chest 64 okay so I
have to focus now I really want to win
why do people play this this nonsense
all the time really nobody interested in
any real game right we place III III h 3
like you play for a draw from move three
right okay why not play d5 get something
interesting going
yeah my reading I had a bad session last
weekend and this is also not very good
III what like what you play III and and
and g3 yeah okay the the Kings gambit
hmm I don't know I mean I want to get my
rating restored maybe I should actually
play something crazy the way the way I
play at the moment seems so awful maybe
something crazy as is in order now he
managed to box in his own Bishop here
the bishop has more squares I'm
threatening me five and yeah so I can
take this now i believe and i will a
central pawn I cannot resist
okay let's wrap this oh no it's not
lunda h7 please oh what the hell you
mean gambit no no sorry I mean have some
respect for Jessa the halloween
government is just complete crap I mean
I'm willing to do some things but I'm
not going to not going to blunder a
piece on move form
yeah so I try to snatch this Bishop
which looks like is successful going to
take it next and I have a pretty good
center you know what's going on then
she'll be nice people everything's cool
no reason to to argue or what what's
going on them so deformed let's push the
pawns and have the bishop am on top of
it so let's keep this yeah benko gambit
would get the job done I'm pretty sure
about that but people play this kind of
stuff entire chest just don't don't try
for anything
yeah I try to be quick here also not
wasting time here I probably don't get
anything sophisticated done so let's
play simple and quick moves if possible
let's let's trade stuff iam wow you want
to have the worst porn structure ever
right it seems that this is this idea
okay that looks funky
yeah I think you will probably lose one
of those bonds Bishop to h6 it's
possible on you can also do this here
the bishop would be great on this
diagonal there goes the a porn
yeah this is the switch to swiss cheese
formation definitely is clock this is
the without Luke formation okay at least
I'm ending this streak of funerals
resides that's good gain start and now
let's see if I can get the better of the
Blitz skin what is the Blitz kick up to
this is a funky lighter i can go d for
him and sacrifice a pawn later it seems
it's not interested okay isn't this good
for white first first glance i would say
it should be good for white is this
thing but it's not really something that
i know all that well castles bishop age
six looks pretty bad
g6 Bishop h6 also looks kind of
interesting okay but but okay I can't
cancel first of all he has to watch out
for g7 at samsung moment now basically
basically app I was threatening night
each other and i have c 3 ready if I if
I if I need to and I have this yes so
here this is an interesting thing I can
place you form or c3 c4 looks far more
tempting just blast everything open if
he takes maybe 96 you know and sorry c4
takes Bishop before route 96 this kind
of thing could be interesting I'm much
better developed here
ship g7 doesn't help c3 is normal see
one looks super tempting i do that sorry
there are a couple of questions and i
cannot really answer them because this
game is kind of its it's sharp i have to
have to keep keep an eye on it there
should be four nights is 65 this kind of
thing let's do it it looks it looks like
the right thing to do I'm if i compile
the repertoire like the recent things
that I did it's basically the same thing
as if I would look at the opening for my
own games I I try to check best the best
play if and see what the strong players
play those kind of things and it's very
comparable to that process so now i can
go d 6 or i can take it sex both looks
pretty strong take it sex taking on g6
doesn't help this looks good let's do it
maybe it is sex only five or something
but i am not sure Bishop f8 i go back to
a form
our dad has a question about visualizing
a chessboard i I really don't know then
I'm sorry about that i cannot even tell
you what I visualize to be honest okay
so i just keep keep the structure with
this king boxed in I just now come on f5
now it must be really okay after years
when I gon be five so i have this I wait
actually I can do this right attack the
book look f8 Bishop c6 and that's it you
cannot prevent queen of eight mate yeah
that's end of game
at 65 I just take both pieces yeah
that's that's the end this is the end
I'm not saying now is letting the clock
run down Bishop e7 maybe it's that on
let continue someone at least okay take
it shop here and look at five should do
the trick but the look you want this
hanging actually so after go queen here
right for Queenie seven made it's got
queen d aid this is a look up at the end
is there something else that I can do it
you to win even more clearly you look at
five it's nice but it somewhat doesn't
doesn't do it okay again if i go here
and this is actually this is actually in
clear all right if I go here yeah I
don't want to have some weird Queen
trade and then then play with the play
against those pawns I just want to make
keep the mating attack on and TM rook
and peas up
check check check
check time warning check black forfeits
due to this connection okay I'll take
that there was a nice one right funny
attacking game yeah this line is
interesting the two nights there's a
question by George isn't Bishop h5 more
critical um I don't really know I think
I mean it's the more the sharp a movie
abisha page five I'm sorry about that
but I think why should be objectively
better last time I checked at least so I
started with two wins and I had three
losses and now I have two wins again
very low hitter all right okay game
started Tim glute with black yeah
disconnection is the poor man's way of
reasoning Tim glute Grandmaster that's a
yeah I can always screw up his first
name yakap yakap from glute yeah as a GM
so let's see is playing the Italian game
and they all play this nowadays a
four-night 83 yalla yalla yalla and as I
mentioned more than once it's not bad
again i miss c6 you're right i wanted to
the set i would play the car o and again
i forgot to do it yeah I'm really sorry
this is not I'm not doing this on
purpose ya hear t include he has a
pretty m
he has a pretty high rating usually is
much lower he's a good GM but not a
usually high rated blitz player I don't
know what I'd what do I do here keep
tension I'm actually happy that you did
that not that it is bad for him but at
least now I I have an idea what the
structures I wonder if queen is six is
something wrong did not let's just play
normal moves there are some endings here
that wouldn't be all that bad some night
against bishop here would be okay
especially and gallic night to c5 and
son okay so he actually gives me the
default witches I'm kind of surprising I
mean this is some real power down the
diva he has rookie one doe green be six
green be six was a little bit annoying
creepy six ok I'll go here first
that's a discussion in the chat if saga
kayak and the Challenger for the world
title is considered traitor by
Ukrainians um well I don't really know
if there is a particular least strong
opinion about this in the Ukraine
however what I would i have to say is
that yeah kayaking had some some
statements in recent years clock that i
found a little bit unsettling to be
honest he very openly supported yeah the
the sub politics by Putin especially
regarding now human rights that they do
a little bit strange okay so I try to go
to d2 and yeah why does a little bit
it's a little bit Stern uncomfortable
him I don't know he cannot move the
Queen ready to prevent Queen d2 and I
queen e to I take you for justice gives
away just gives away upon
it's a bit awkward this position let's
see what i can do against mr. gloom to
have a 5 out of 5 squad so it's a bit oh
it's a bit of awkward here really so and
what is he trying to do if i go Queen d2
he might play he might play quinta f5 he
might do that it's an interesting thing
i mean i can check take him and he has
got check on c 8 mm my queen is
dangerous though
hmm i'm unsure but if i don't do that i
don't really see how i'm getting
something going in so what i can do is i
can play a check and clean f4 for Queen
trade
it could be good actually check check
just like that I didn't consider this
even because it gives me this great you
five square but maybe I'm just not
seeing it right I really thought that
this wasn't wasn't on
looking Josh I don't think so this I
think will be very tough for white yeah
so here I can already win stuff right
and it was that was already critical
anyway i will keep everything on dark
squares time morning so he wants to go
King d3 wow this is something I have to
after check here let's do this Bishop
see 695 should you win I think his king
is completely boxed in yes youporn
shouldn't be that dangerous he cannot go
here can I go up
oh I don't have had kept a lot of time
it's a bit surprising I didn't didn't
see that my time was actually ticking
down it's good yeah before into the fork
gimme gimme pawns what's going on here I
have no time here time
six bloody seconds what an awful thing
to do I have losing this this is really
really absurd really I completely I
completely dehart did not check the time
I mean that was really awful such a
clear clear way of winning yeah anyway
okay um I screw it up unfortunately so
that was a way I'm ready to give him a
win anyway thanks guys for watching it's
a bit of a shame if I would have this I
think I winders I don't get it night is
sick so stupid ready why don't I go up
with a king with such an easy win like
this yeah I don't know anyway guys hope
you enjoyed the session it was a bit of
an up-and-down affair I can certainly
play a bit better than this but I still
feel it had some entertaining moments
yeah okay guys I'm back next week next
Monday um that also would be the regular
time for the u.s. viewers because the
time chase changes synchronized so
thanks a lot I'll be back bye-bye
you